we should I was talking about rejection
on the question about the twilight zone
book yeah we'll talk about is that's a
big one with people being rejected into
mu went back to saying some of your
friends at this worldview of sort of old
studio model yeah I think a lot of
people even in Generation X Generation Y
have this one night shining armor
approach to their career yeah in what
way in a sense that we if you just have
that big break life will be grating that
penis so some taste maker will put a
standard approval do we want you want
the fairy godmother to tap you with the
wand you know you want you want to be
easy you know and you know and sometimes
you here we go okay yes let's talk about
that for a minute okay because okay it's
wonderful when you have dreams of glory
as a creative artist as a writer
filmmaker director producer whatever and
the fairy godmother comes into your life
and she taps you with the wand and
everything is perfect and everything is
easy and you never have to share to hear
this rarely happens first of all I don't
mean to burst your bubble but fairy
godmothers are not real they're
imaginary creations so but many of us
would would love it's like oh my god wow
if only JJ Abrams you know read my
script and loved it and then suddenly
I'm on top of the world right now first
of all because I know a lot of these
guys it ain't like this it's like this
the whole careers like this and fukuyama
del Toro my different Guillermo he you
know his dream project is a project
called at the Mountains of Madness it's
based on a novel by HP Lovecraft he's
wanted to make it for 20 years and last
year about two years ago James Cameron
right on the heat off of avatar said you
still want to make that let's make that
and he came aboard his producer gamma
spent a couple years developing an
active development studio studio
development at Universal Tom Cruise was
slated the star was Ron Perlman who IMO
works with off and he started Hellboy
because we going to be in 3d amazing
film and
the studio wouldn't green line it 200
million dollar movie r rating or already
movies ever made that you know made that
much and you know they just wouldn't do
it so here's guillermo garibai tell
tomorrow James Cameron Tom Cruise you
think of course they should they're
going to say us know heartbreak
heartbreak and then you just go on to
the next project you just keep going and
maybe that movie will get made and maybe
it won't and you know all of us have
those projects let's dream project don't
get made but if you save yourself well
you know you know I'm going to go to
Kickstarter I see you I think what's
going to inevitably happen ultimately is
some guy some a-list guy some huge guy
is going to come to crowdfunding it's
going to come to Kickstarter or
IndieGoGo and it's going to say okay I
need 50 million bucks and that's going
to happen and then the world is going to
change the world is absolutely going to
change because you know i mean when i
was when i was growing up Orson Welles
was still alive and I always thought
thought that there should be a box on
the income tax form that just said if
you want to give a buck to have Orson
Welles make a movie check this box and
then just and then he wouldn't have that
spend the last several decades of his
life in frustration never making a movie
he just would have gotten the money and
make movies because he was this genius
and we would all be better having these
guys making their movies so the point is
that for all of us this rejection for
all of us there's disappointment and
then it just becomes how committed you
are to what you're doing and and you
know
and again it goes back to if you don't
need to be rich if you don't need the
studio's the network's you really have
to really look at your dream and say
what is my dream and if you if you slice
it up into little pieces and you say
okay wait a minute do i need this piece
of the dream or is this the piece that I
really care about because then it allows
you to maneuver you know and like and
also another thing that we do all of us
is like for instance Guillermo you know
he might do one project and that doesn't
even realize but he might take something
from that project and put in another
project for instance the vampires he
developed in blade two he ultimately
fully much more fully realized in the
strain which was a series of novels with
you visit that more recently so and what
I'm doing in Space Command is I'm taking
certain elements from various projects
and then putting them into this into the
umbrella of this project simply because
they fit they work their great
characters or great aliens or whatever
so that so it's not that that you're
recycling in any negative way but you're
certainly looking at the things that you
care about and making sure they get to
the audience
you